my guest today is general robert
spaulding author of stealth war and he's
uh been on valeating multiple times he
has his own show called generally
speaking his expertise is china cyber
security foreign policy
national security policies and he was
the former senior director to national
security council
and he's here to tell us and educate us
on what really happened
with the colonial pipeline general
robert spalding thank you so much for
being a guest somebody taming again
great to see you again patrick yes
brother so what robert what is going on
i mean i got a lot of different data
they
did they pay the 4 million dollars to 5
million to hackers biden's refusing it
happened this is the largest
5500 mile canola colonial pipeline
i'm in florida right now it got hit many
different states got hit
what can you tell us about what really
happened here well i don't i can't tell
you exactly what happened because i
don't you know work for the company but
you know it sounds like they were hit by
ransomware
and if you know anything about
ransomware uh
they um basically lock down your systems
and
tell you if you don't pay we're not
gonna unlock them and not only that
we're gonna delete all your data so
uh that's enormously as you know
valuable to a company so they'll pay
almost anything
to to get that unlocked and it sounds
like that's what happened here
in this case so is there a formula for
ransomware on asking the right amount
money to get where the company is do
well you know um i don't know if you
remember the the hijacking of ships that
was going on near somalia
but um there was a they knew you know
what the cargo was worth they knew
how much the company was insured for
they knew so
it was a calculated business decision
and when they negotiated with
the hijackers in somalia i mean they
knew their business
down to the penny so i would imagine the
same thing
goes on for these um for these hackers
they they
understand the the nature of the company
and then they basically figure out what
they can extract and
and i think for them um it's
it's not like just a smash and grab
it's a calculated business decision so
in many cases like in the cases of the
smalling hijackers they had funders so
they may these guys may even be
funded by somebody they've got bills
they've got to pay i mean this is a
business for them
and unfortunately we've created this
vulnerable infrastructure that allows
these businesses to thrive
how how much is this is going on right
now are you seeing a lot of this take i
mean obviously this has been going on
for a while
but the tactic then approach probably
has changed are you seeing a lot more of
this happening today
no i don't think it's anymore i think
it's just pervasive across
industry one of the things that got me
you know
focused on china was really
understanding that this was going on and
when people think about this they just
think about the hackers they don't think
about the social engineering going on
and the profiling of the company
these these hacks can be very
sophisticated in the way they work and
in many ways can have state-sponsored
activity behind them
you know in the case of some of the
companies i looked at it wasn't so much
as a cyber hack as it was a human hack
and you know they're using social
engineering i remember in one case
they basically found out that the guy
that had
the keys to the the servers
was actually a football fan a college
football fan
and so they crafted a newsletter for his
uh
football team because they knew that he
got it and then
they embedded in that newsletter a link
that gave them access so many times
they're looking at facebook profiles of
these people twitter profiles
they're they're surveilling the company
who has access
and then they're trying to figure out
what can what does this person click on
what are their habits
so it's a really sophisticated uh human
engineering so it's social engineering
really and
and it takes a long time to really
cultivate
targets in in this manner it's just not
like
uh you can spam people but a lot of
companies are getting sophisticated in
terms of what they tell their employees
about how to be careful about things
some of the things i've seen have been
generally basically generated for the
person the single person
that they know that they can get access
to the system do we know
how uh this dark side hacker group
that's uh
uh from russia do we know how they
hacked into
the colonial uh pipeline has that come
out public
no i don't think so but i would imagine
it's some kind of social
my my guess uh would be that some kind
of social
engineering they found out uh somebody
uh that they wanted to target they
they they sent them i would imagine
some kind of phishing mail email and
then they clicked on a link that they
probably shouldn't have clicked on and
and the company had access um through
that it's very hard to just
uh break into a system most companies
have firewalls and everything else so
they're looking for somebody
to do something that prevent provides a
vulnerability that they can exploit
you know the thing that really people
ought to be concerned about is not only
is this happening to things like
colonial pipeline
uh we saw where um a um
probably a state sponsored um
hacker was trying to put chemicals
into water treatment in a city in
florida
we've seen the christmas bombing in
memphis where it took down
uh first responders in this in the whole
cellular network for att in
tennessee for like two days uh last
christmas so
there's all kinds of infrastructure
attacks going on that
you know when you look across the in the
country we've got a big problem here in
terms of vulnerabilities
yeah that's very obvious and by the way
we're not talking about a small company
we're talking about
5500 mile pipeline
transports a hundred million
gallons of fuel a day this is a
sophisticated company it's not like
they're
they probably have cyber security
insurance they probably have the right
analyst they probably have the right
team in place so this could happen from
the smallest company to the biggest
company
we we've done these you know my wife
this will typically happen to us it'll
happen
at least once a week they'll get an
email saying
hey jennifer uh coming from me said hey
jennifer i just want you to know i
forgot your phone number can you please
email it to me so i can call you back
and jennifer will come and she'll say
babe did you email me this i said babe
why would i email you this this is
i'm your wife i'm your husband i know
your phone but they'll do this
and so many times so now we have a whole
team that
looks out for this but no matter what
you do
they seem to still be figuring out a way
to how to get in there
what can companies do to prevent this
from happening
well it's really about in teaching their
employees
to do just what you did which is or your
wife did
basically come and ask you did you
really send this if you have any
suspicion
first of all don't click on any links i
think that's the biggest thing you know
when i was in the pentagon
the joint staff got hacked and it was
basically somebody clicked on a link in
an
email that they shouldn't have clicked
on uh and then that that case it was uh
it was the russians that that we
reported
that had done it but i mean this stuff
is going on all over the country i think
the the problem is
people don't realize how vulnerably
vulnerable our
infrastructure in our companies and our
government is to this type of thing
and we've looked at warfare through the
lens of you know f-35s and tanks and
ships and bombers and
i flew bombers but quite frankly warfare
is coming to our shores
into our own living rooms just like you
said into your wives
uh email because this is the way that we
that we that we undermine our the
economic the social
and the political fabric of our society
today and that's what's going on
in the big time by the way there was a
guy named roger robinson who worked in
the reagan administration
and they um what they did back in the
reagan administration is they
s they slipped into russia's
supply chain of a valve that
ended up creating the biggest explosion
non-nuclear explosion in history was
witnessed
by our satellites in space in in the
soviet union
and so infrastructure attacks have been
going on through nefarious
means you know since the cold war what's
happening today
is that we've connected all of our
infrastructure and our companies to the
internet
and that means anybody at any time can
be attacked
today this this makes me uh
this makes me think about i mean
obviously you look at the stats we've
all read the stats 68
of gas stations in north carolina
reported fuel outages according to gas
buddy roughly half of all the gas
stations in georgia
south carolina washington dc and
virginia also reported outages
there was an interview done this morning
on fox business with mario barteroma
where john
casti matadis who's a billionaire says
the payments have been made to the
terrorists
i understand from my sources that four
million dollars was paid he's calling
them terrorists
i mean we don't know who these people
are and you know what
what makes me think about this as you go
into it okay so
gas prices beginning of the year around
225 they hit 303
that's a 40 increase 35 percent increase
like this
when you and i spoke last time i mean
we've spoken and you got
millions on top of millions of views
where you were speaking from experience
as the former senior
director national security council do
you think this
is a you know because they're saying
maybe this is
because if you go on dark side's website
they'll say here's our business model
here's who we've hacked before here's
who we've gotten money from
we're not political we're not religious
matter of fact we even have some values
and principles we don't target funeral
homes we don't target health and
there's certain things they don't do so
these are very value-based
criminals if you want to call them so
they're even telling you how they go
about doing business
do you think this is at all linked to
the man at the top
of putin who is you know encouraging
this to take place
or do you think this was just a couple
guys you know an organization that's
making money and this is their business
model
well i i mean that's the whole point
right we don't know and we don't even
know if it's the russians i mean
it could be uh coming from anywhere it
could be coming from within the united
states i mean that's the nature of
cyber attacks today um and you know so i
mean it's very hard to say
uh who it is or even what their
motivations are
like it's funny because you know we we
said that uh all of a sudden
uh the lockdown stopped the coronavirus
in china
you know we can't even believe that so i
don't i would not believe
anything that these guys said because we
have no way of verifying that
information
i was talking to bernard carrick today i
said you know he was here on the podcast
you know bernard carrick is a former uh
commissioner of nypd 55 000 employees
and he also was the commissioner of the
correctional department of new york so
he ran the prisons and he ran uh uh
nypd and i said how do you deal with
things like this he says typically
you know when when when we find out the
business model of criminals who do these
types of things
it takes us a while to adjust okay and
get better at it i said so who's more
creative
the criminal or you know the
organization nypd dea
cia fbi whoever maybe he says it's
typically
the criminal is more creative than us
but we try to make adjustments
let's just say you're in charge right
now okay and
you get as much intel as you can okay
how are you pivoting to protect
you know this from happening because
this affects the nation this affects the
populace this affects people being
scared
i'm in dallas yesterday running a
meeting my wife says the moment you land
go to the gas stations i'm like for what
i'm in dallas she says baby you haven't
been following the news i said i just
had a meeting with 2 500 people i've
been in a meeting from 7 00 a.m
to midnight i don't know what's going on
she says go look at what happened i'm
like oh wow i didn't know this was
taking place
but how would you be handling a
situation like this yourself to
make sure this doesn't happen again i
know you said training education all of
that but
how do we even go above that do you go
do the business model of the movie catch
me if you can with frank abigail do you
do you get some of those guys in to say
how do we go even track where this is
coming from because you know it's very
easy to do a proxy you know
proxy wars oh it's the russians but it's
really china oh it's the chinese but
it's really in the states
oh it's really so how how do we find out
the fingerprints on this because
that's really what we really need to
figure out the fingerprints how would
you go about doing that
well so first of all i you know if i was
going to put
time and i had the resources and i was
in charge what i would do is go about
protecting our infrastructure in the
country so
it would really be about preventing this
from happening in the future you know
one of the things that we did during the
cold war
is that we decided that we were going to
focus on growing our economy so we
invested in infrastructure and
manufacturing and science and technology
we haven't been doing that for a long
time what one of the things i said
is that we needed to rebuild our
critical infrastructure today you could
light off a high high-altitude nuclear
weapon over the country and shut off the
grid permanently
and that would be you know devastating
for our society you saw what happened
after katrina
so it's really about strengthening and
hardening our infrastructure our
scada systems that power our gas
power our electricity it powers our
water it
powers our transportation our banking
system our roads are crumbling
you know we've been spending almost a
trillion dollars on defense
for the last 25 years and it hasn't
really helped us
very much in in these cases and so i
would re-prioritize
spending on defense i would cut the
defense budget
by something like 10 to 25 and i would
reallocate that
that money into building a new
strong critical infrastructure that
protected the society from these types
of attacks
we see them happening every single day i
mean think about it this
you know you were in the army you what
would what would you do
if you were you were coming under
constant attack every single day
i mean you would beef up your defenses
you would basically go out and go on the
offensive
you know in this case we have to
actually think
into the future let's don't go back and
try to catch a criminal
let's strengthen our society so this
doesn't keep happening
what do you mean by by going on the
offensive do you mean offensive like
offensive let's go spend money in person
so one of the things so one of the
things that you would do
um you know if you're you're at a
forward operating base you would go
outside the wire and start
going on patrols so we'd actually be
looking for these people
you know aggressively and they can be
found it's just that
you know right now what happens is
colonial is not the government right
and so the government is not going to
protect protect colonial colonials got
to protect itself
that's why they paid a fine you know if
if
you believe that economic prosperity
is a key component of a functioning
society
and you're allowing your society to be
rated
then you're not defending the
sovereignty and independence of our
country
today we have equality under the law we
don't have economic opportunity part of
the reason
is because we're allowing our companies
to be destroyed in front of us
you know i was taught to drop bombs on
companies
when we wanted a policy enacted
elsewhere like in kosovo for example we
dropped
bombs on factories of the henchmen that
were supporting milosevic
that's how we got milosevic to stand
down because all of his support wilted
away
say this one more time you you were
instructed to drop bombs on companies
we took out the the assets the factories
that were owned by the henchmen that
were
supporting milosevic that was what was
done during the coast of war
war to get the serbians to stop killing
the kosovars
and that we had to stop milosevic so is
using military force
to achieve a political objectives the
way we did that is by going after the
assets
of the people that were supporting them
what i found in 2014 when i started
getting into this is
you know you can take out a assets with
the jdm you can also do what
exactly happened to colonial you can
begin to
take out things using cyber use social
engineering
you could own the supply chain just like
i talked about with what we did to the
soviet union so there's a million
different ways
that you can attack a society and that's
what's going on we have a society that
has been
we're thinking in terms of this 20th
century uh way of protecting our society
like
you know somebody's going to drop bombs
on us no they're going to attack our
economic our political our social or
financial system
relentlessly until we are broke that's
the goal
and that's what you know the russians
the chinese the north koreans the
iranians
the most prolific are the chinese but i
mean they're all coming after us and
and quite frankly we are not thinking
and we're not playing the right game and
that's why you're talking about cutting
defense 10 or 25 percent and taking that
and putting it into a different
infrastructure because wars are not
being played the same way as they were
played 20 30 years ago
uh and it's going a different direction
by the way just out of curiosity
since we're already talking about this
i'm going to take it on the angle with
since your background has national
security and foreign policy
uh what what's going on right now with
palestine between hamas and israel okay
obviously we've seen it we've seen the
videos we've seen the stories we've seen
one say if they want to come against us
we're going to go we saw what
ben responded with and it keeps
happening there were more events that
took place today it was still ongoing
how ugly can this get or do you think
this is going to calm down and it's
going to be the traditional
war that they keep having you know every
few years you think this can get ugly or
you think it's going to calm down
no i think i think i think the trump
administration basically looked at this
and said look we're not going to let the
palestinians get in the way of middle
east peace anymore in fact they're out
of the equation
we're going to go after whatever peace
we can we can achieve
and i think what's happened is the
palestinians see in the bible
administration an
ability to basically tie peace in the
middle east to solving the palestinian
issue
and that's an issue that you know from
my perspective i don't think palace the
palestinians want to solve
yes arafat had the opportunity to solve
this
and basically decided not to he felt
that he could make more money
by continuing to be you know prevent
that from happening so
i think the palestinians think they have
an opportunity to basically
go back and and re-litigate this again
and i think you know
the trump administration was really
achieving in the in the last part of the
administration was really
achieving some goals because they said
look we can't solve the palestinian we
can't basically
solve all of middle east peace and by
saying hey
we have to solve the palestinian issue
first no let's start let's start going
after those
low hanging fruit anybody knows that if
you're trying to solve the hardest
problem first
you're and you're making everything else
contingent on that
then you're going to be you're bound for
failure and i think that the palestinian
sense that and i think that's what
they're um
that's why they're doing this well
what's the right move to make today for
u.s what is the right movement u.s to
make now obviously we're not a trump
administration we're a bitemen
administration it's a different one what
is the right move for america to make
that we're watching this taking place
they're going back and forth
it doesn't seem like it's slowing down
obviously you know we know
historically israel has got one of the
strongest air forces i know everybody
knows how powerful
their hamas is you know they're uh
what is it assad is their secret you
know the intelligence they gather
they're one of the best in in the
around the world but what role should
america play in this
well i don't know there is a role for
america to play in this i think
one role we shouldn't play is to
basically say
um when the israelis respond to attacks
and provocations to say
hey guys cut it out you know don't stop
stop you know responding to the
provocations and attacks
i think quite frankly it let let the
israeli settle it and
don't in any way
support or give any kind of credence to
or or support for what the palestinians
are doing i think
that's what they're hoping to see they
want to they want to see something
any kind of sliver of sign under the
body administration that would give them
indication that
they're going to come down on israel um
to to prevent them from
responding to their profit provocations
and attacks i saw earlier today biden
talked about the fact that they're going
to stay out of their way and kind of try
to let them hash it out which i think
you probably agree with that decision
but you're seeing a lot of people on the
news that are saying things like i heard
a story
from trevor noah he was explaining this
whole thing and he says okay i don't
know i know people are going to get
upset but
when i was a kid and i was growing up
you know
my i would fight with my brother and
sister and one time my younger brother
hit me and i hit him back and my mom
said why would you hit somebody that you
know they can't hurt you
why hurt somebody that you know they
even though they hit you first
there is this fantasy of
hey i know they're bombing us but we
know you can destroy them
just let it go just let it go
why is it so important for netanyahu
to not just look the other way instead
to retaliate
what what is the downside of him not
retaliating versus him retaliating
i think if you don't retaliate if you
don't um deal with the the attacks and
the provocations and you invite more
it's it's it's you're inviting me it
happens all the time
did you just say you invite more you
invite more you invite more attacks now
all of a sudden you've got
the the lebanese um coming in and
joining in
and maybe even the syrians you know you
have to
it's it's really you know one of the
things i remember about
the the trump administration i was
actually at mar-a-lago
um it was back at the hotel and i knew
that she
was um having uh dinner with the
president and then
i saw the strikes uh happening in syria
so
the the strikes happening in syria were
twofold one was to
uh basically deal with the use of
chemical weapons but also to tell she
that you know hey i'm i mean business so
in a lot of ways you have to basically
meet provocation with strength or else
you're inviting more attacks
i had a cia agent on last week mike
baker i think his name is michael baker
and interview hasn't come out yet but
it'll come out here soon and i was
speaking to him i said
uh question for you on who is the best
you know secret agency you know
intelligence agency in the world of
course we got cia mi6
assad uh mossad all these other ones
that are out there
which one would you say is the best one
is it israel is it ours is it uk's
and he said it's us's agency that's
better than everybody
of course you have to say that because
that's who you represented you were part
of it for nearly 20 years
but here's a question for you how
superior
is china's intelligence agency
today because that name is never dropped
amongst the other mi6 is china kind of
looking around saying please don't put
us on that list because we kind of like
the fact that none of you guys know
how far ahead we are of you how much
more advanced we are of you
because all the three names you're
talking about they're innocent we're
willing to go places
that they're not willing to go how would
you describe to the average person
you've been
you've lived in china i think twice one
time you went there as a in what you
were in the air force and then you came
back and you went back again and you
were
a general in the air force so you've
been studying the topic of china for
quite some time matter of fact when you
were the senior director one time
at the national security council you got
up to kind of give a briefing to
everybody about what really
why china is really the biggest enemy
and you have mcconnell sitting on one
side biden sitting on one side one's a
republican
whose wife has got family over there
with the big construction company and
you've got biden obviously with his son
having a relationship with china and
then six months later they fire you
uh maybe you triggered something when
you said that but how strong
is their secret you know intelligence
agency against all the other ones in the
world
well i think it it's a it's a strength
of their system
and and it's a fact that everything and
everybody
is responsive to requests by the chinese
communist party if you're a student if
you're
if you run a company i don't know if you
remember
but you know if you're a billionaire in
china you can just be disappeared
uh you know look at jack ma look at you
know
a bunch of other billionaires that have
basically find found themselves you know
out of power so their system is one
in which the party requires
people to do things uh and and doesn't
take no for an
answer and so um you know we think of
okay the
if you get hired by the ca cia that's
one thing
if you're if you're running a company
you know you're not part of the
government you're not supposed to be
doing anything
funny business uh the chinese communist
party doesn't see the world that way and
in fact they
enlist everybody the entire population
in one way or another they either use
indoctrination to basically
you know give a party line but they also
use
the fact that you know uh companies
chinese companies are global they use
the fact that
the the market of china is an incredible
draw
for other companies so one of the things
that just recently
happened i don't know if you saw uh
shanghai expo
a girl gets up on top of a tesla and
starts jumping up and down and saying
the brakes are bad and
and i got bad service from tesla what
happens
so they do they do they smash that
protest
you remember this is a country that
killed 10 000 people in tiananmen square
no
no they videotape it and it goes on
national media all over china
and then it's picked up on social media
don't buy tesla cars
buy chinese electric tesla's the number
one selling electric vehicle
in the market in china now they're down
27 percent
cri it's falling like a brick what are
they doing there what was that about you
know so
who is who is the target ultimately of
that attack
the target i would say of that attack is
elon musk
and the target of that attack is not so
much tesla
i believe as it is spacex why
spacex is building starlink what could
what could starling do
starlink could could transmit into
the mainland china and provide internet
to the people of china
i think that's one of the things that
the chinese communist party is concerned
about
and so they basically want to send a
lesson to elon musk
and now you know he's trapped he's
basically
sold the market on the fact that he's
going to have all these sales in china
they've got him they've they've hooked
him and and this is what they do
i've seen it over and over and over
again what they wait till they got you
they got you hooked and then they start
to
turn the screws and you don't even know
what they're trying to get
right now and then i saw a report you
know the you know officials at tesla are
trying to figure out
what do they even want they they may not
even tell you what they want
um until you know you they they've let
you kind of swing a little bit so
this is the problem with the chinese
communist party is it's not just their
their they have impeccable impeccable
um intelligence services because they
collect so much data on us and
and have ai that they that they run in
fact you know
they say they want to become the saudi
arabia of data
for their ai their ability to collect
intelligence on us from your smartphone
everything around you
so they have an incredible machine that
is
merged with their commercial sector in a
way that
that quite frankly we don't understand
and we don't we
we don't look at jack ma and say hey
jack ma is not only working for the
chinese communist party he's also
working for alibaba
so you know you don't you you didn't
even know he was a communist member
until he came out and said so and then
you know of course they they
they deposed him from his role as a ceo
so
this is a system it's a far far more
um dangerous system than we've ever
faced
because we've allowed it to come into
our midst
so so the concern is if elon musk does
what he wants to do
and he provides free internet for the
folks in china they may be able to get
on facebook twitter create those kind of
accounts
where folks around the world can really
see what's going on in china rather than
being able to control
and silence everyone in china is that
kind of what you're saying
that's what i'm my saying
do you think they will ever have freedom
of speech to the point where we can
actually see what's going do you think
it'll ever happen
no i you know i think silicon valley
made such an incredible
model for dictatorship i mean it
it's beautiful because you can you
collect all the information about your
entire population
everywhere from everything that they do
cameras that are around the city
you know all the transactions they make
you figure out what makes them tick
what are they responsive to they have a
sick kid you know they have a mortgage
that's going bad does they got a
business that's going back
and then when if you need if you need
something you begin to turn the screws
or you know if you if you don't want
this person to to be a success because
ah they're they're a non-conformist they
don't they don't they don't like the
government they don't like being told
what to do
okay well you just basically say hey
their kids can't get into school
they can't get a mortgage you can't get
a job you know it all becomes
related you know when you have this
global
uh globalized uh uh economy
and internet where everything's
connected you when you have financial
relationships within when it with a
regime like that and they can pull the
trigger what did they do
with uh the nba uh when daryl mori
talked about hong kong
what did they what did what did lebron
james say he came out and said
well the nba better not say anything so
here is a a a national basket
basketball association in the united
states basically being told by one of
its players
that the chinese communist party showed
up and said shut up and you better shut
up
um i've seen this time and time again in
u.s corporations so
you know we think that we live in a free
society in
reality our society is being engineered
for us right out from under us and we
don't really understand it because
we don't think in terms of um this this
digital world
that by the way we created silicon
valley created this
uh i've asked you this before i'm
curious to know what you'll say today
what are your
top three biggest threats we're facing
today in america not
worldwide specifically in america if you
were to say number one is this number
two it is number three is this what
would you say it is
i think number one is the fed i think
the i think the fed is gone
off the rails you know they believe
there's no inflation going on
i think deflation's showing up in the it
has been showing up in the stock market
showing up in real estate i think it's
showing up in things like bitcoin i mean
people are just losing their minds
trying to figure out how they're not
going to lose the value of a dollar
so i think the fed's a big problem i do
think that
the political system is a problem i
think the parties are focused on
themselves not on what the american
people want and i think we've engineered
this
system through both the the introduction
of dark money
but also in terms of the way we've
structured the
the the voting system the election
system what i'm talking here about is
closed primaries
i'm talking about the fact that if you
don't do what the party says they'll
primary you out the next time so
i think the political system is a big
problem and i think
the um the the unwillingness
of the federal government to really
focus on the things that matter to
uh you know alexander hamilton
understood industrial policy
he understood economic strength he
understood that national security
you know united states security came out
of growing the economic power and
prosperity of the american people
and to do that you had to you had to put
the american people first
industrial policy you know we don't have
to have a centralized economy
but we do have to recognize that other
countries germany
japan china in particular have
industrial policies that are that are
set to erode the economic productivity
of america i think having the government
understand this
and really you know focus on economic
prosperity of americans is is really the
the the third and in our industrial
policy the third
piece of that and so you know financial
i think political
and i think economic uh is our number
one two and three uh
problems in this country you think we're
about to have a third party after what
happened with liz cheney and how she
opposed
the republican party has been now
divided into two you think it's going to
turn into
something else or i think they'll
eventually unite
um you know i really um you know i
really subscribe to what katherine gale
and michael porter wrote in the book the
politics industry i think what happened
in alaska in november is going to is
going to happen more
i don't think it's we're going to have
three parties well i think what's going
to happen
is you know particularly what happened
with all the mail-in ballots in in the
in the november elections
where you know state secretaries
basically
came up and and unilaterally decided to
send out you know massive mail
mail-in ballots i think this the
legislatures are standing back up and
saying
hey no we had a constitution we had a
state constitution said
in our u.s constitution said this
legislature is supposed to
uh determine voting rules not not the
executive branch of a state so i think
you're starting to see votes in that i
think you're going to see people stand
up and say look i'm tired
of the parties not doing what i asked so
um
it's not about liz cheney it's about dc
that doesn't work for the people anymore
i think many people would agree with you
general spalding thank you so much for
your time appreciate you
thanks great seeing you again yes
likewise take care pretty powerful and
concerning isn't it if you enjoyed
what he had to say and you want to know
more there's two videos i want you to
watch one of them
is an interview he did with a hacker
chris roberts where he talks about the
alarming
you know challenges that we're facing
with cyber security today in america
the other one is the interview i did
with general spalding where he got
deeper into how china
silent takeover of us while the american
elites
slept that's his book stealth ward that
he talks about china got a few million
views if you've not seen this one click
over here
if you want to know more about cyber
security click over there thanks for
watching everybody take care bye